one of game of thrones' longest-running
bad guys remained a mystery to readers
and viewers until the HBO series eighth
and final season the night king the
ancient creature who created and led the
formidable army of the Dead we still
don't know much about the white Walker
King but from behind the scenes tidbits
to fan theories he is the untold truth
of this menacing bad guy lavake an actor
Vladimir fur dick might be the most
recognizable face of the night King at
this point but the truth is he only
started playing the character in the
show's sixth season prior to that the
role was played by Richard break best
known for films like Batman Begins or
Kingsman the Secret Service
breakin fur dick actually overlaps while
break was playing the night King verdict
played the high ranking white Walker
that Jon Snow shatters two pieces with
his Valyrian steel sword the transition
between the two actors was so seamless
that many may not have noticed though
some fans found it breaks appearance
even more frightening verdict was an
indispensable part of the Thrones team
long before he stepped into the night
Kings frozen shoes he worked on
everything from the fight scene at the
Tower of joy as well as performing and
working on everything from high Falls to
intense sword fights when it came time
to recast the night King there was no
better choice than fer deck who knew the
show's action set-pieces inside and outs
though the night King's human name is
never revealed and audiences still don't
have a firm handle on his personal
history the show did confirm during
season six so he was once a human he was
a member of the group known as the first
man and he was used as a pawn by the
children of the forest the children of
the forest made a home in Westeros long
before humans existed and were settled
happily in the Seven Kingdoms until they
were forced to deal with the first man
after the first man crossed from Essos
into what is now dawn they came into
conflict with the children in the end
the children were responsible for
creating the night king when they took
one of the first men hostage and plunged
dragonglass into his hearts in doing so
they inadvertently created ultimate evil
by making the first-ever white Walker as
a means of defending themselves against
man you
you may devote meters we were at ward
looping slaughtered the creation of the
night king turned out to cause more
problems than it solves
after all an undead monster who can
raise entire armies of zombies is bound
to cause a few issues he turns against
the children of the forest and they were
forced to fight back when the first men
and children of the forest found
themselves under attack by the white
walkers the two warring factions were
forced to team up and work together to
save both ultimately the first men
triumphed at the Battle of the dawn
after the war was over the first men
worked with Giants and the children to
build the wall White Walkers have always
been a big part of thrones' mythology
correct student of history are you after
all the show's pilot opened with White
Walkers attacking members of the Nights
Watch every now and then at drawing the
show's earlier seasons viewers would be
reminded that no matter what else was
going on in Westeros the White Walkers
were still out there and ready to attack
you might think the knight King has been
around for the whole show but he
actually didn't make his first
appearance until season fours Oathkeeper
that's the episode which finally reveals
the faith of the many babies if you were
saw offered as sacrifices drawing the
audience's first ever glimpse of the
night King he turns a baby into a white
Walker throughout the series the show is
diverged dramatically from the books
author george RR martin for his part has
a lot to say about the knight kings
history and especially wants to make
sure people don't confuse the two
figures he sees as a specially distinct
the night's king and the night king none
of it confused the night king audiences
know when fear isn't the same as the
night's king as Martinez explains the
night's king is a legendary figure like
bran the Builder in the books the
night's king was an early commander of
the night's watch thanks to an ill-fated
love affair he turned against the watch
causing the king-beyond-the-wall and the
king in the north to band together and
take him down this little distinction
might not seem important but ultimately
it serves to distinguish two similarly
names but radically different characters
as the night king makes his way through
the icy north and builds up his army it
remains a mystery as to what he wants
beyond destruction death and to move
beyond the wall in spite of that
inscrutable 'ti verdict has made some
executive decisions about his character
motivations throughout the show hints
are dropped about why the knight King is
who he is
and does what he does in various
interviews verdict has said that he
thinks that the night king wants revenge
for being the night king in the first
place
as a result of years of conflict or
mistakes the night King became the night
king against as well and to spend the
rest of his existence trying to fight
back against those who wronged them the
show also gave viewers one significant
piece of evidence about his motives in
the final season second episode a night
of the Seven Kingdoms bran stark reveals
a night king will come for him to
accomplish his true purpose an endless
night he wants to erase this world and I
am its memory that's what death isn't
one of the longest-running theories
among Thrones fans argue sir upon brands
transformation into the all-knowing
three-eyed Raven
bran stark has actually become a part of
the night king himself throughout brands
training with the previous Raven he
found himself able to walk back in time
and see previous events drawing one
visit to the army of the Dead he ended
up branded with the night Kings mark a
twist that left some viewers looking for
deeper meaning his mark is on me he
always knows where I am one of the most
popular theories circulating on this
topic suggested that bran could have
walked to the Past to prevent the
children of the forest from creating the
night king but in doing so he became
trapped within the night king in some
way an intriguing theory but now that
the night king has come for bran and
gotten himself murdered in the process
we know it's one that was obviously off
the mark in trying to figure out the
night Kings true origins numerous fans
have wondered if he might have come from
a noble family like the Lannisters
Bolton's or Tyrells as far as ancient
houses go Targaryen is certainly one of
the oldest around and many viewers see
rise that the night King might be
descended from this royal line after all
he can ride a dragon and he likes
arranging carnage in a spiral pattern
however the Targaryen connection is
pretty easy to debunk considering the
timeline doesn't really allow for it
that theory while interesting has been
moot for some time the more appealing
theory points to the night king being a
stark especially since fans know for
sure that the night king was one of the
first men who are a Starks ancestors
it's possible that a stark ancestor was
a man who eventually became the night
King which explains why he always seems
to hunt members of the stark family in
particular they're his family
but they ultimately turned on him the
showrunners for Game of Thrones have
clearly had long awaited plans that are
just now coming to fruition the fact
that it was Arya Stark and not Jon Snow
or someone else who would eventually
kill the night King was something the
showrunners had planned for several
years as far as the night king goes
they've been carefully considering this
character for a long time however that
doesn't mean they've shared those plans
with the actor who actually plays the
night king in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter verdict revealed that
the directors and showrunners were as
silent as a famous character no they
didn't give me much there are a couple
of discussions with the directors but
nothing particular about what he was
supposed to do verdict indicated that
since he got the sense that they knew
the character inside and out he didn't
necessarily need the same information no
matter what you might think of this
approach it certainly didn't affect the
storytelling Orford XP creepy
performance fire has long been one of
the most important weapons deployed
against whites they're zombies created
by the White Walkers
a body can be reanimated if it isn't
incinerated which is why the biryeo
rights for the Nights Watch involve
cremation
luckily Daenerys Targaryen and her team
of a vital resource that could help
fight against whites and White Walkers
dragons which can soar high above the
battle unleashing dragon fire on any
enemies below the night king obviously
has an affinity for these beasts
considering he took down one of Daenerys
dragons during the show's seventh season
but during the long nights it becomes
clear that even a living dragon it
wouldn't be an effective weapon against
them
Daenerys tries a tried and true burning
Trek but the night King just stands
there staring completely immune to
dragon fire
it's embarrassing really as the night
king and his army advanced on Winterfell
characters wondered how they'd possibly
prevail against an army that could
simply continue multiplying throughout
the nights the battle itself was
relentless pitting the north and their
allies against a massive army of the
undead as the night King made his way to
the godswood to find bran it seemed as
if the end was nigh and the army of the
Dead would finally triumph even though
the northern squad knew they could
destroy the entire army if they only
took out the night King the chances of
them doing that seems to me best
thankfully there was one fearless force
running around the most viewers to God
about halfway through the episode
specifically arya armed with high
jumping skills and a dagger of Valyrian
steel thanks to years of training as an
assassin and the element of surprise
I was able to finally put an end to the
night king and the army of the Dead what
do you say to the god of death not today
even as a professional stuntman verdict
wasn't immune to the grueling schedule
of filming the long nights filming the
episode required a 55 day shoot over
several nights in Belfast that many
members of the cast and crew bluntly
described as miserable when speaking to
The Hollywood Reporter fer it looked
back on the shoot as extremely tough
this was one of the hardest jobs of my
life it makes sense besides performing
as a night king he also worked with
nearly every other actor to rehearse the
fight scenes and choreography one of the
toughest scenes to shoot understandably
was firlock's final scene with Maisie
Williams Azaria kills him it was a very
emotional day and night it was very very
difficult we have very good friends we
know each other it wasn't easy for me to
pretend to hurt her if you make a bad
move if you don't grab her well she
could have an injury so I was under
pressure and she was under pressure it
was not an easy day verdict worked with
Williams on a fight with Gwendoline
Christie is Brienne so the two have a
stronger combat history together
clearly it paid off with the perfect
shot check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]